this case has major implications both
legally and politically so let's bring
in the experts CBS News legal analyst
Ricky cleeman and our chief Washington
correspondent Major Garrett let's start
with Ricky this is not only the only
legal case involving the former
president uh Ricky he faces special
counsel investigations into the January
6 attack on the U.S Capitol possible
mishandling of documents that are marked
classified Georgia prosecutors are
investigating interference in the 2020
election So based on what we know about
this case here in New York what kind of
charges could the former president be
facing
in New York we have not seen the
indictment we will not see it until it
is unsealed in court but we can make
some assumptions and in New York we
certainly by basis of Michael Cohen's
statements after he is testified for the
grand jury as well as the statements of
Trump's lawyers we have a belief that
this is a
set of charges many many charges for
falsifying business records which have
to do with a legal Arrangement that
really wasn't a legal arrangement with
Michael Cohen and the president for the
president to be able to pay back Michael
Cohen because Michael Cohen had fronted
the hush money to Stormy Daniels when
they needed to keep her quiet about an
alleged Affair or a tourist before the
2016 election
falsifying business records in New York
is a misdemeanor no matter how many you
count they're misdemeanors so we believe
that it may be tied to a campaign
violation because it wasn't declared and
that way it becomes a felony so you go
from a one-year crime to a four-year
crime now I've got to add we don't know
what else is there is there do you think
there's something else there people on
the outside looking in or saying it's
about what campaign contribution storm
Daniel is an adult film star people say
who cares what do you think about
nothing but well it's it's many people
will say much to do about nothing he's
still we still say no one is above the
law but when you look at this case Nate
they go why well perhaps why first
because the counts that uh and the
investigations that Vlad has mentioned
really have to do with offenses against
the United States of America and those
are the ones that people seem to be the
most interested in are you surprised by
the timing of this Ricky now oh I was
shocked by the timing I have to give it
to Alvin Bragg I have to give him credit
he fooled all the people all the time
that there everyone believed the
newspapers online every TV outlet that
this grand jury was going on Hiatus for
one month and then surprise yes and and
so for that I give him credit at the
same time he has to accept
responsibility that he did this on a
Thursday afternoon which gives president
Trump former president Trump the bully
pulpit for a lot of days until that
indictment is unsealed we also have to
remember there could be from the Alan
weisselberg investigation accounts
having to do with tax fraud having to do
with property inflation deflation and
Karen McDougall because there was a
payoff to care